so Takeda fights with these bladed whips
and they're used in his normal attacks a
lot of special moves which one do you
want start with do you
I will start with Shira Ryu if you read
the comment and you know that Takeda
grew up in the Shira Ryu and he was
trained by scorpion himself and you'll
also notice like in some of his costume
there's some there's some yeah so this
one now you almost messed it up man I'm
small boy start off like there's also
visual indicators for each of the it's
kinda admitted with Melina which I
apologize for the visual indicators to
show you I mean obviously they'll tell
you in the top what your playing is but
what if they join together here for
together his ninja mask so what up let's
go over his common moves so commonly as
I said the bladed whips are a big part a
lot of his normal attacks he's got some
of the best reach in the game a lot of
these normals have huge range so he gets
the places crowd and he had a very very
far distance but he still does he still
have an up-close game as well he does
and that's what's cool about it is these
whip attacks have long range but they're
a little bit of a slow sign but then his
ninja training kicks in and he's got
some kind of fast ninja type moves if
you want to close the distance or if
you're stuck up close so he doesn't he's
not only good far away mm-hmm he's
pretty well rid of it so then his
University special moves he has his
torpedo hit which you can control the
distance you can do it close or medium
or far you can do in the air so there's
a lot of options with that and you can
use this to you know close the distances
easily or you know if you think the
phone's gonna do a projectile and want
to pick up your projectile then he is
this really cool
ninja dagger which you can use as a
projectile or you can use it as a mix up
option like we were saying you can do an
overhead into this low and the ex1 is
especially cool holds out three you can
charge it and then you can let it go
whenever you want so you can kind of
hold it out and get in there for more
combo to run up to them or maybe try to
threaten them and then you jump in or
whatever you want to do and they have to
sit there and be scared about
alright x1 it's right then this other
Universal move is this combo starter
it's kind of - punch and it's like a
combo filler move you can do it get some
damage right and the ex1 is a combo a
starter so give you a little bar okay
that one and pop them up and then you
get a jump combo which that was not that
was not unfortunately that's the first
drop of the day surprisingly didn't come
from you yeah all the fans are like can
you get some of you doesn't drop combos
yeah yeah that's weak and right and then
what's special to this very so the
sharayu Takeda he gets some wit moves
that are kind of inspired by scorpion he
has a grounded one and then he has a
jumping now normally they don't go into
combos but if you do the ex version he
will get a combo you can see it kind of
and then the really cool thing is the
quick face was a teleport uh-huh and
it's kinda like scorpions you just do it
there's a quick teleport they restart
yes watch another intro we can yeah this
is not talk reptile I will rip out your
throat settle down we have no sound on
the TV so that could have been the same
intro yeah we have no Jim it was right
yes so normally you just have your quick
little teleport but then the cool thing
is he can charge it and choose when to
let it go or cannot let it go at all
also you can cancel oh yes right and
then the ex1 is a combo starter and
looks awesome then the air teleport are
also has an air towel or does and check
this up very fast and it recovers so if
they're jumping off your head jump up
not the more interesting thing is you
can let it miss and then if they try to
do anything you can
you know combo them or whatever it's
like very tricky and the ex1 is even
trickier because he goes the other way
and then doesn't overhead it I didn't
know what was happening there I was lost
so he has four really cool teleport
moves and the spirit moves mm-hmm so
that's your riot push you should throw
away oh he has a cool throw
that's gonna sting all right so should
we go into the next one yeah next one's
gonna be Lasher where his whips are
electrical charged and it's gonna be
more of a long-range combo heavy one
you'll see in a second his special moves
are pretty cool so we're seeing a
student versus master here yeah I felt
it was appropriate
nice job going cannon here little board
that's enough yeah yeah I always think
you know you can't do it but every time
you prove me wrong
yeah yeah thank you very surprising what
have you become I returned to service
then a human right you are your enemies
I don't know what scorpions said we do
seem angry
yeah I've never seen really a happy
scorpion true he doesn't even like
Teddy's yeah that's true he doesn't like
teddy bears so Liam
last year is all about range she gets
some really good new normals the
slowpoke here that's long he gets that
Fist of Fury punch move gets turned into
this much lower range oh man he gets
kind of a low scoop food it could trip
you up and if you make it bounced up
more and then he gets a really strong
anti-air whip you can also be used in
combos as like a combo indirect or combo
extender or you can end the x1 and a
splat and kind of run up to them and mix
them up why don't you show us something
there all right
that's why are you ready go ahead yeah
there are some more so you didn't drop
it the game dropped it from now yeah so
yeah I think this one would be best
played at kind of this jump in range and
it'll be really good I think this is
another one where the combo artists are
really gonna like messing with us and
something you know we don't talk a lot
about but I think it's nice for those
you know we have a lot of fans who play
in turn for a lot of fans who are very
good at the game we also have a lot of
fans who don't play a lot of fighting
games there's love Mortal Kombat and a
term that I think is good for everyone
who plays games to use it's kind of what
you alluded to there is called footsies
and like seth's where your character
wants to stay in relation to like their
longest range move yeah the footsies is
basically you controlling the space of
your characters best attacks so a
perfect example would be this character
where just move right here this overhead
with tons and tons of range
Derek if he was fighting me he would
have to be very wary of the Subura even
from this far out I know that one of
these boots and he would have to commit
to doing a teleport which if I tell my
blog you know that I could punish it or
he would have to attempt to jump it and
that's when I could use this move
exactly
I read a lot of message boards that
about people you know who love the game
and I can't wait for Mortal Kombat but
they want to get better and like that's
just kind of one of those entry-level
terms that once you start thinking about
you'll start getting better you just
kind of understand that yeah and
footsies does a kind of thing where no
matter what level of play right you do
it you might just not know that that's
what we call it right yeah so is that it
for this one yep all right what well but
what what one get a full beard okay
thanks ever an expert Takeda is this
interesting because it's done in the
boss
[Music]
well that necessary is my question like
the foot to the face after it's just
Grandmaster to his father figure yeah
right that's that let's uh let's check
out the last variation all right this
one is very very interesting and I think
the beautiful thing about the variant
system is you'll have maybe ones kind of
on the simpler side it's more basic than
one could be you know like a the
opposite of that and then there's a lot
of these that are really really
interesting and unlike the other
variants at all it really stands out and
this is one of those examples I think
that myself well well there I found
myself with some of my characters I'll
have to I'm really good at and now I'm
kind of like well I should probably the
third one too because you have all of
this range well you got me think that's
gonna be the really cool part of the
depth of the game yeah
I've just started flying with our Mac
but cuz I want to learn yeah I sensed
your arrival because I wanted you to I'm
clearly in the presence of greatness
so in Ronin in addition to the whips he
also gets dual plasma swords and that
will change a bunch of his normal
attacks which is something that somebody
would need what why not just have whist
because and he also gets a bunch of
additional special moves this is the
only variant where he has a projectile
yes kind of a beam and the projectiles
are not something we've done in MK very
often so it's pretty cool and you get
some projectile reflect
[Music]
please always work out again
professionals and then they're really
the cool thing is you can as you'll see
you can drop the sword on the ground and
you can choose the distance you want to
drop it and then you can kind of play
this game and at any time you can summon
it back up off so you can kind of do
stuff where you throw it down and maybe
you know you're trying to throw your
projectile you're trying to get those
out no I was going to drop the sword on
the ground the person in the background
just came up and grabbed it and ran away
what the dog sitting up in its mouth I
ran away
yes and you can you can do full combos
yes the x1 he gets a full combo if it
hits and you can do it in a block string
so meaning at the opponent's blocking
and you think they're gonna continue to
block that would be your chance to throw
the sword out and have it active you can
use it in offense like I said defense
with projectiles or often so you can
have it out and then Derrick's sitting
there scared blocking on us here and I
can kind of run up go for combos throws
whatever you feel like doing the world
is your oyster
it's your oyster okay it is I we also
use maybe a master of storms but on
Twitter actually wanted to see so that's
cool nice job hello you know I listen to
the people you do how you want to finish
me up here
let's see whatever you want to show that
I think we do we're gonna do that we
really want to do that I want to do it
oh that's good I don't know if the
stream wants that though they do they do
I'm a little disturbed bro I'm gonna go
ahead and say I'm even a little despair
as one of my faves
that was that was different I think now
we should go through some